lille a fait un bon jour alors quelles
sont les revendications tout simplement
du personnel pénitentiaire alors au vu
de la gravité de la situation le
personnel pénitentiaire demande tout
simplement la réduction drastique de la
population carcérale tout simplement en
aménageant les peines de courte durée ou
encore celle des détenus âgés ou en
remettant en liberté
les prisonniers en détention provisoire
alors nicole belloubet la garde des
sceaux a annoncé la suspension des
parloirs pour les familles et les
proches des détenus mesures
insuffisantes pour le personnel
pénitentiaire d'ailleurs je suis avec
aurélie bollain du syndicat unsa ufap
qu'est ce que vous demandez concrètement
vous aujourd'hui
alors bonjour oui pour notre syndicat ça
fait à peu près une quinzaine de jours
que nous avons alerté l'administration
sur cette situation
nous préférons toujours agir en
prévention que dans la réaction
c'est exactement ce que nous avons fait
puisque malgré les annonces différentes
du président ainsi que du premier
ministre
c'est seulement aujourd'hui que nous
avons arrêté tous les parloirs ainsi que
les activités alors que nous demandions
d'abord une réduction de ceux-ci pour
pouvoir empêcher une propagation du
virus à l'intérieur de la maison d'arrêt
puisque nous ne savons pas comment cela
peut se passer dans un espace confiné
nous ne souhaiterions pas que ni les
collègues ni les personnes détenues ne
soit atteinte
donc il nous a fallu attendre
aujourd'hui pour que nous soyons enfin
entendu même si cela reste encore très
peu puisque il ya des gels qui ont été
livrées il y a des gants certes mais il
manque encore pas mal de matériel comme
les masques au cas où il y ait une
infection qui qui commence pour que nous
puissions être protéger les personnes
détenues comme les lits surveillants
pénitentiaires et leurs familles